[音楽]
んだった
ああああをた同県いるぞ
はいどーするん
シーズをいきましょう夫妻
まず始めしたそうですという今ですね香川県に来てるんですけどもはじめのファン
クラブのおかげでですね月に1回遠くにこれるのがとてもありがたいです今月もやって
いきましょー心霊スポット巡りでございます
香川県そんなこういうイメージないんですよね無数の今日食べたうどんとかめっちゃ
美味しかったしなんかちょっと静雄ことにだような空気感じだってすごい僕好きだった
んですけども私で幽霊の方はどうなんでしょうか
から先日霊媒師の人に占ってもらったところ僕は幽霊に使えないらしいので一応今回も
今度はバターの何も起きないなということで後輩を連れていこうと思いますで早速新で
スポットに行きます5調べてめちゃくちゃ強いところにちゃんとサーチしたね行くよ
はいというわけで香川県の住んでスポットのチェックまできました
今日も運転は生むのヴァイスさんレスありがとうございます
んですねアイスライミング荒れてます
ない空 emmy アルダー sa コンセプトはですね生後元なりゃいいかわから
ないんですけども整合前半期前コースでをボックスっていう場所があるらしいでござい
ます電話ボックスのスムースコートなんてそもそも珍しいんですけどもその中でも香川
県にあるということでですねどんなことがあるかと言いますとですね事故や大気現象は
よく着てるみたいでございま
深夜あかねが付いた緑色の講習ネオ box にしただけのようなものを見た人がいる
あの人の証言では見つめて背中を向けたスーツの男性が浮いている時間へ角度人により
見えたり見えなかったりするらしい人影がよく見えるこいつ寝過ごす覧ください評価が
高いですね欲し五ツ4.35ですよ
月なやつね
サクサク奥入瀬です結構栄えている街がここら辺であるんですけどもすぐこれとにこの
レベルというかなりレベルの高い号数電話ボックスが春らしいでございます加工は息
できなくなるし
入ると
廃炉さーん負けでって言ってるんだとわかんないと思うんでいきましょう今回なんです
けども全然3人って何も起きなかったんで今からてぃんぐだ言ってきまーこんなつっ
すぐでん楽勝なんですけどしていくぞいきましょうえっ
[音楽]
[拍手]
てまいりましたね
[音楽]
ていました
意外と実はですねー
ここらへん車通りも多いしねえ
方向が何ら頭ないんだ実はあ
圧迫簡単
かんちゃんと健闘ポイントはカンペンドンピックプートンて
ペンとんぱーそ根本ほんとピントんですか
[音楽]
いやでもやばい俺感じるは月1何でも感じない
もう
[音楽]
西5.9とこ探されていると名宝展を探そう
ビッ
[音楽]
だが多分あるだがられ高 s 見てるわー
それがた沿ってないめっちゃだったんですよ
[音楽]
多分コレですねええっっ
入って三
見てみたい
だから入るわけで妻と言っ
[拍手]
でっかちか違うじゃないん
なって動くんですよ感ですね何が起きたんすけど
ルーティンてんだっはいでも半値お金濃い濃い濃い濃いトークなんて全然
結婚ガチャパン食ってるなぁじゃあなんか
バッチって良かったと思います
須磨区の富山から助かった
超ワーンってなったですなんかなんか急にバッジが付いたすんだけど
ほら一間にこんだけじゃんけたらもっとバラバラにカチカチっていいのに今5台になっ
ているそうですよ
勝ち
秋笹沖の空気ますよホント
[音楽]
にいます入っ
取り憑かれないから大丈夫
はっはっは
おっ
一括やむを得ないかトカゲがいた僕にと議員だよ
うわー最悪気
そこのもう
雲言うし
めっちゃいる羽田ますかチェーンでもするよああいいですね
ためねー
[音楽]
金があるん
上抜き組の次せず何よ
なっていっ
しっかり美しさ
ジャンク上でしょ
住民が100円しか入んないから事実化を払います
5000冊はい姉様どうするどうするパッチャー米顔でこうね
故福田さんこんに使ってよですふっ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
終わったーーー
あの黒色ですからじゃあねハッハッすごい偶然京都も止まった本当になりました
米だと思っていますかいいですかぁ4倍チーズ
あの
何もお金がなくて10円だけ借りともいうかいいです
のでお会いしますなんかもうすごい
非常に近くにコンビニとかたでござるあれは滑っあるあります
昆明にはずれてってもらった
全然いろんなあった米ガーネッ
今はこれなんかでいいですかねいやいやむしろよ救世主所
間違って埋まってくるでしょ
で待って本当に遠くな園芸ブーツ
みんなセラー盤園から web 学生数あるする国を置いてます
ハイパスもありますよねを制限を打ってきましたね
長女ですまだちょっと怒ってください
解けしました贈っ時の時3月にはこれをやられています
世間にはん
くろこっぺあーございますが薄すぎないこれで無事
受けたは4つ手に入れたんでこれで戻りますよろしくねはいありがとうございました
本当にじゃあ頑張ってください
これからもおいしいよ凄い気をつけてねはい
ニャティティ
ん
はいというわけですねもなんか怖いとかよくわかんなくなってきました3部の
マネージャーさんが車に待ってるんでその1人こそで電話してみましょう本当に心霊
スポットにある電話ボックスだったら何かが ok でかもしれないんですよ
上べくではないんです
メッチでき組めよ
なんで怖いよ空気が違うんですよ
それじゃあ気取らない
でもすごいやばいはやっぱりですよねー
思いまってトカゲ動く
またすげーた以上で待ってやばい
下がった分立名細お礼がさぁお金に入れるからさー
ナンバーでごしてもらっていいカメラん彼らさぞより物は
と思いました
よって両ぱっかもしれん
[音楽]
だったら全然を買ってきたん
保証しはいえ誰ですか
はあああああああああ
あああーーお久しぶりです
今まさに寸0スポットにいるんですけど
[音楽]
おめちくっつき服ねー
やだホントにやばいまずで終わる
den
太っ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ani
ねすごい一斉にさんいろんな人から line 来てんだけど価値っ
海で級のからめっちゃいい+けど助ける死ぬ死ぬ
1貫来ないよぼく何でえっかーっ
なんでこのタイミングまず自分は世界に一気に人から連絡きた今じゃこう書くなよ
あんまり普段連絡しない人から一斉に来たまずやばいねここだか心霊的なものという
よりなんか不思議な感じがすごい
今日出会った人から昔の友だち
アリーナいにん2から連絡が来るその様子は
まるで
私お電話ボックスに近づけないためのように見えた
本当に俺はな
入って良かったのだろうか
work